serge halimi président du ppm le parti
progressiste martiniquais dans sa
déclaration de rivière blanche revient à
ses fondamentaux
l'autonomie pour la martinique oui c'est
tout parti qui a une philosophie et une
doctrine qui a un projet et surtout qui
est ancré dans l'histoire du pays
nous avons toujours défendu l'idée de
l'autonomie de la martinique c'est à
dire un processus de responsabilisation
qui est liée aux grandes initiatives
prises avant moi il fallait absolument
le rappeler à haute voix et de la
manière la plus moderne et la plus
claire et plus cohérente
en gros il nous faut absolument faire
reconnaître notre personnalité collectif
nous ne sommes pas une population en est
un peuple
ainsi bien de le dire il faut le faire
admettre
nous avons une langue qu'il faut
absolument faire incontesté du créole et
nous revendiquons depuis des années un
doigt à initiatives locales comme on
traduit ça a bien je suis dans la même
foulée d'idées que emmanuel macron qui
dit qu'il faut donner un pouvoir
normatif c'est-à-dire adapter les lois
et les règlements sur place dans chaque
région
c'est pas au moment il dit c'est que
nous nous réaliser nous devons
absolument à la fois revendiqué sa tout
en étant dans l'article 73 et au sein de
la république française
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une contradiction
de vouloir l'autonomie c'est à dire une
plus grande liberté de manoeuvre plus de
pouvoir pour les élus locaux plus de
compétences et prérogatives aux les
collectivités les institutions locales
et en même temps rester sous l' empire
de l'article 73 qui nous concept qui
quand même limite l'initiative politique
vous savez la réflexion est binaire en
france et même mentalement ici chez
certains de nos élus c'est soit on est
dans le 73 donc dans ce qu'on appelle
d'identité 10 la tib les lois qui sont
votées au niveau national ces replis
qu'automatiquement ici ou soit on les a
en deux heures c'est à dire l'article 74
qui est pour moi un statut néocolonial
on vous exploite distance la france est
la deuxième puissance maritime mondiale
par ses étendues océanique sans pour
cela est appliqué l'égalité nécessaire
aux populations de la polynésie où
d'autres peuples
pour moi ce n'est pas possible la
conquête de 1946 est à préserver et à
renforcer si l'égalité des droits socio
économiques culturelles et juridiques
civiques et civils tous et douala il
faut pas qu'ils peuvent toucher à ça
cependant nous avons un autre combat à
gagner qui est la différenciation de
l'application des politiques nationales
c'est pas pour ça qu'on est des
indépendantistes je le dis très
clairement c'est pas pousser non plus
que cette revendication est complexe
parce que c'est pas la culture de la
france que je vais m'en fermés dans le
73 et considérer le mime et yves
effectifs boïko la loi qui est voté à
marseille est applicable ici
automatiquement donc nous revendiquons
la possibilité d'avoir un pouvoir
normatif les et locales pour adapter les
règles à la réalité locale dans le
domaine de l'urbanisme demande de
l'énergie dans le bain du développement
durable c'est une revendication à mon
avis extrêmement saine clair et net
nous voulons rester dans l'europe nous
restons nous voulons rester dans la
france nous restons mais nous sommes un
peuple
nous sommes dans la caraïbe on ne peut
pas ignorer notre géographie mondiale ni
notre culture ni notre identité est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une contradiction entre
que vouloir rester dans le statut actuel
tout en réclamant des pouvoirs
supplémentaires alors qu'un avec
l'instauration de la collectivité
territoriale unique de martinique
nous avons déjà eu sept la romantique de
la satisfaction de cette revendication
comment vouloir aller plus loin mais en
même temps rester dans le même cadre
au fait je vends partie deux erreurs le
résumé le destin d'un peuple à un numéro
si vous résumer les ça ne peut pas un
numéro 60 74
on est véritablement mal parti la
deuxième chose la revendication du clae
activité unique
c'est une revendication qui nous permet
d'avoir une cohérence des politiques
publiques nessma pouces a causé plus de
pouvoir vous confondez compétences et
pouvoir
vous confondez décentralisation et plus
de responsabilisation plus qu'en plus
nous mêmes constitués des politiques
adaptées à notre réalité est ce qu'on
peut continuer à avoir trois jeunes sur
quatre partir ne revenant pas d'un pays
on est en haut du suicide collectif
donc il faut prendre des mesures
spécifiques dans plein de domaines y
compris la migration au taux dé
politique de natalité des politiques
d'immigration des politiques d'emploi
sur place pour permettre le maximum de
martinique a travaillé est ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer qu'on puisse mener une
politique de développement durable en
ignorant que nous avons des puits de
d'énergie et puis nature et le monde
sans adapter les textes qui sont
localement le fait de demander plus de
responsabilités et de rentrer dans un
processus d'autonomisation et bien ça
tombe aussi su ce qui me semble permet à
la france de dire nous sommes un pays
diversifiée et nous ne pouvons pas que
avoir un plaidoyer esthétiquement la
diversité mais restituer l'honneur de
cette diversité
la dignité de cette diversité aux
peuples qui habitent dans ces pays
peuple martiniquais peuple guadeloupéen
les autres peuples d'outre-mer
quelle formule juridique conviendrait le
mieux à ce souhait d'autonomie c'est à
dire de plus grands pouvoirs de nos élus
et de grande émancipation de notre
peuple sachant que la constitution
permet plusieurs types de formules et
notamment si on voit quelle est la
nouvelle calédonie la con ce sont des
exemples de forme juridique qui sont
hors du schéma classique que nous
connaissons ici ya une dynamique qui
existe
on ne peut pas être la foi aveugle ou
sourd par rapport à cette dynamique
si la dynamique de l'autonomisation dans
plusieurs régions de responsabilité de
reconnaissance nos patrimoine collectif
ces vacances c'est la cata une autre
revendication mais si la nouvelle
calédonie mais c'est aussi la martinique
c'est aussi la guyane demain bon c'est
trois en dix questions et veut conjuguer
des deux choses le jour à l'égalité doit
différence ou la différenciation de
byzance de politiques publiques
je considère que l'article 73 peut nous
permettre d'aller le plus loin possible
si vous ça que nous proposons une
adaptation de l'article 73
quand on a une dimension économique
forte parce qu'on peut difficilement
parler d'économie sans parler de pouvoir
fiscaux ou des pouvoirs d'organisation
sociale ou d'organisations technique et
nous demandons donc la première chose
qu'il y ait un pouvoir normatif qui
soient données aux collectivités la
deuxième chose il faut un pouvoir
législatif ça existe déjà c'est
l'article 73 5 alinéa 5 de la
constitution qui permet d'être habilités
pour faire la loi les martiniquais ne
savent pas que la région martinique que
j'ai présidé a fait plusieurs lois dont
17 lois sur la politique énergétique
une loi sur le transport martinique
transports qui a été installé mais ça a
été installé par une loi locale graal du
pays quoi c'est très un bon ton prono
pour mettre en cohérence les politiques
publiques du transport et puis une loi
sur la formation professionnelle
nous pouvons y dicter la loi c'est pas
parce que nous exprimons besoin
d'organisation globale et que nous
sommes en dehors de la république je
considère qu'on peut absolument utiliser
les duos d'une cohésion
quand vous employez comme la ppm emploie
le mot autonomie vous savez que ya une
large fraction de la population qui a
peur et de l'autonomie et de
l'indépendance considérée comme un pas
vers la misère la pauvreté langage de la
mère patrie de la métropole coloniale et
c'est de notre imaginaire collectif
anciens est ce que ça ne risque pas de
crisper les gens de fait on perd à
nouveau de cette notion de ce concept
que vous promouvez aujourd'hui oui il
faut d'abord clarifier les choses nous
ne sommes pas pour l'indépendance à la
martinique et nous ne sommes pas non
plus pour le statu quo ou n'ont pas
bougé on a déjà fait un pas c'est la
collectivité unique
comment on peut aller plus loin c'est
vrai vous avez raison que ces mots et
frais mais c'est de la responsabilité
des élus de claire de ne pas ma kai et
de ne pas tourner autour du pot je pense
qu'il faut nous pédagogie de
l'explication la responsabilisation la
responsabilité de montpon du vraiment
totalement nécessaire au moment où la
france et l'europe sont dans des limites
budgétaires très compliqué quand on a
des changements climatiques qui fait que
notre résilience
collective est touché quand on a besoin
d'être compétitif et dans la région dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons et tous ces
éléments plaident en faveur de plus de
responsabilités locales tout en étant
dans un grand marché français et
européen
donc il faut faire acte de pédagogie
d'explication pour rassurer tout le
monde et je pense que il faut pas qu'on
nous dise qu'on attende qu'on le dise
c'est par là la sortie il faut plutôt
qu'on prenne notre destin amer conçoit
pas spectateur de l'avenir sans pouvoir
agir sous nos propres nos propres pays
et nos propres destins enfin dernière
question
serge letchimy cette pause et
d'opposition la déclaration de rivière
blanche et elle signifie telle la fin du
moratoire sur l'autonomie décrétée en
1981 par aimé césaire et les dirigeants
de l'époque du bpm moi je pense
honnêtement que nous mettons fin à une
période un peu flou créé par cet essai
c'est ce long moment après l annonce du
nouveau toit je dois dire clairement que
aimé césaire dans le processus avait
déclaré le monde wamu donner un contexte
précis mais il n'a jamais abandonné le
combat bonne autonomie jamais abandonné
et à ce titre là nous ne faisons que
renforcer une orientation qui l'avait
épuise en disant clairement que le parti
progressiste martiniquais justement au
moment où on a beaucoup d'histoires
martinique et politiques et personnelles
il faut observer sans feu sans sans
faire de commentaire nous devons
redonner aux idées de la place au projet
de la place un exemple précis
quand je dis que il faut absolument que
l'europe et la france puisse faire jouer
la clause de sauvegarde pour la
production locale endogène du pays même
c'est à dire le marché observe pour
quelle raison on donne un système de
quotas pour exporter la banane et pour
quelles raisons ils n'ouvrent pas le
système de quotas pour voir importer des
produits que nous produisions ici mais
c'est un acte politique majeur qui est
institutionnel et qui pourrait permettre
l'éclosion de la production locale
quand nous disons qu'il faut absolument
que l'article 3 5
en oeuvre soient appliquées nous
permettre d'être en connexion avec la
caraïbe et qu'on parle d'erasmus aider
les jeunes qui peut toucher des
mexicains des brésiliens des cinq lucien
des dominicains pour avant un brassage
coopération caraïbes quand nous disons
qu'il faut une interconnexion
énergétique et permettent à des
présidents aux présidents de
collectivités de pouvoir signer des
accords de coopération plus directement
sous l'autorité de l'état
parce que je souhaite que les pouvoirs
régaliens d'état demeure à l'état c'est
quoi c'est une possibilité avant une
diplomatie territoriale économique
efficace vous trouvez d'autres segments
et secteur où nichent de développement
parce que s'ils ne le faisons pas ça on
aura une fuite de la jeunesse
considérable et on va se retrouver de
60% à plus de 60 ans un peuple vidé de
son énergie et une population sans cap
gemini ainsi